Esta noche quiero tener una conversación sobre
este increíble tema global
de la intersección entre el uso de la tierra, la comida y el ambiente,
algo a lo que todos podemos relacionarnos
y que he estado llamando, la otra verdad incómoda.
Pero primero quiero llevarlos a un pequeño viaje.
Visitemos primero nuestro planeta, pero de noche,
y desde el espacio.
Así luce nuestro planeta desde el espacio exterior
a medianoche, si pudieran tomar un satélite y viajar
alrededor del planeta. Y lo primero que notarán,
claro, es qué tan dominante es la presencia humana
en nuestro planeta.
Vemos ciudades, campos de petróleo,
incluso distinguimos la flotas pesqueras en el mar,
que dominamos gran parte del planeta,
y principalmente mediante el uso de energía
que podemos ver aquí de noche.
Pero retrocedamos y bajemos un poco más profundo
y miremos durante el día.
Lo que vemos es nuestros paisajes.
Esto es parte de la cuenca amazónica, un lugar llamado Rondônia
en la parte central sur de la amazonia brasileña.
Si ven con cuidado en la esquina superior derecha
verán una delgada línea blanca,
que es un camino construido en los 70.
Si volvemos al mismo sitio en 2001
encontraremos que estos caminos
se desplegaron en más caminos, y más después,
al final de los cuales hay un pequeño claro en el bosque
donde habrá algunas vacas.
Estas vacas se usan para carne. Vamos a comérnoslas.
Y se comerán básicamente en Suramérica,
en Brasil y Argentina. No serán enviadas aquí.
Pero este patrón de espina de pescado de desforestación
lo vemos con frecuencia alrededor de los trópicos
especialmente en esta parte del mundo.
Si vamos un poco al sur en nuestro pequeño viaje
podemos ir a la parte boliviana del Amazonas,
aquí aún en 1975, y si vemos con cuidado,
hay un delgada línea blanca como de costura
y un solitario granjero
en medio de la selva primaveral.
Volvamos otra vez, unos pocos años atrás, en 2003
y veremos cómo realmente luce
más como Iowa que como un bosque húmedo.
De hecho, lo que vemos son campos de soya.
Esta soya se enviará a Europa y China, como forraje,
especialmente después de la enfermedad de las vacas locas
cerca de una década atrás, cuando decidimos no alimentar más a los animales
con proteína animal, porque podía transmitir la enfermedad.
En cambio, quisimos darles más proteína vegetal.
Así que la soya realmente explotó
mostrando qué tanto realmente responden
el comercio y la globalización por la desforestación de la selva tropical húmeda
y la amazonia, un extrañamente increíble
e interconectado mundo que tenemos hoy.
Bien, una y otra vez, lo que vemos si miramos
alrededor del mundo en nuestro pequeño viaje
es que los paisajes, uno tras otro,
han sido despejados y alterados para sembrar comida
y otros cultivos.
Así que una de las preguntas que nos hacemos es,
¿qué tanto del mundo se usa para cultivar comida
dónde exactamente, y qué tanto cambiará esto
en el futuro, y qué implicará?
Nuestro grupo ha estado mirando esto a escala global
usando datos satelitales y datos de campo de seguimiento de
la agricultura a escala global.
Y esto es lo que hemos encontrado, y es sorprendente.
Este mapa muestra la presencia de la agricultura
en el planeta Tierra.
Las áreas verdes son las que usamos para cultivos
como trigo, soya, maíz, arroz o lo que sea.
Son 16 millones de km² de tierra.
Si los pones en un lugar,
equivalen al tamaño de Suramérica.
La segunda área, marrón, son los pastos y dehesas
donde viven nuestros animales.
Es un área de 30 millones de km²,
o cerca de toda la tierra de África.
una enorme cantidad de tierra, y es la mejor, claro,
es lo que ven. Y lo que queda es, como
la mitad del desierto del Sahara, o Siberia,
o la mitad del bosque húmedo.
Ya estamos usando la riqueza de tierra del planeta.
Si miramos con cuidado, encontramos cerca del 40%
de la superficie Tierra está dedicada a la agricultura,
y es 60 veces mayor
que toda el área que reclamamos para
nuestra expansión suburbana y las ciudades en las que vivimos.
Media humanidad vive en las ciudades hoy,
pero un área 60 veces más grande se usa para cultivar alimentos.
Esto es un resultado sorprendente
y realmente nos afecta cuando los vemos.
Así que no solo usamos una cantidad enorme de tierra para agricultura
sino que también usamos una gran cantidad de agua.
Esta es una foto aérea de Arizona
y cuando la miras, es como:
"¿Que cultivan aquí?" Resulta que
cultivan lechuga en medio del desierto
usando agua esparcida desde lo alto.
La ironía es que, probablemente se vende
en nuestros supermercados en Twin Cities.
Pero lo realmente interesante es, de dónde viene el agua
para este lugar, y viene de aquí,
del río Colorado en Norteamérica.
Bueno, el Colorado en un día típico en los 1950
era como, saben, ni una inundación, ni sequía,
en promedio, lucía algo así.
Pero si vamos hoy, en condición normal
en exactamente la misma localización, lo que queda es esto.
La diferencia es principalmente por irrigar cultivos en el desierto
o de pronto campos de golf en Scottsdale, Uds. elijan.
Bueno, es una gran cantidad de agua, y, otra vez, estamos haciendo minería de agua
y usándola para cultivos de alimento,
y hoy, si viajan más abajo del Colorado,
está seco del todo y ya no llega al océano.
estamos consumiendo, literalmente, todos los ríos de Norteamérica
para irrigación.
Bueno, no es el peor ejemplo del mundo.
Este probablemente sí: el mar de Aral.
Muchos de Uds. lo recordarán por sus clases de geografía.
Esta es la antigua Unión Soviética
entre Kazajistán y Uzbekistán,
uno de los grandes mares interiores del mundo.
Pero hay una especie de paradoja aquí, porque parece como
si estuviera rodeado de desierto. ¿Por qué está el mar aquí?
La razón de que esté aquí es que, en la parte derecha,
ven dos pequeños ríos que bajan
por la arena, alimentando esta cuenca con agua.
Esos ríos están drenando nieve derretida de las montañas
lejanas del este, donde la nieve se derrite, descienden por el río
por el desierto, y forma el gran mar de Aral.
Bien, en los 50, los soviéticos decidieron desviar esta agua
para irrigar el desierto y cultivar algodón, créanlo o no,
en Kazajstán, para vender algodón en los mercados internacionales
y conseguir divisas para la Unión Soviética.
Realmente necesitaban ese dinero.
Bien, imaginarán lo que pasó. Si cierras la llave
del agua del mar de Aral, ¿qué pasará?
Aquí en 1973,
1986,
1999,
y cerca de 11 meses atrás.
Es bastante extraordinario.
Ahora, muchos de Uds. viven en el medio oeste.
Imaginen que fuera el lago Superior.
Imaginen que fuera el lago Hurón.
Este es un cambio extraordinario.
Este no es solo un cambio en el agua y
dónde queda la costa, es un cambio en los fundamentos
del medio ambiente en esta región.
Comencemos con esto.
La Unión Soviética en realidad no tenía un Sierra Club.
Pongámoslo así.
Así que lo que encontramos en el fondo del mar de Aral no es agradable.
Hay muchos residuos tóxicos, cantidad de cosas
que fueron botadas ahí y que ahora empiezan a estar en el aire.
Una de esas pequeñas islas que eran remotas
e imposibles de llegar, fue sitio de
prueba soviético de armas biológicas.
Uno puede caminar allí hoy.
Los patrones climáticos cambiaron.
19 de 20 especies únicas de peces que se encontraban solo
en el mar de Aral desaparecieron de la faz de la Tierra.
El desastre ambiental es muy evidente.
Pero volvamos a casa.
Esta es una foto que Al Gore me dio hace unos años
que tomó cuando estuvo en la Unión Soviética
mucho, mucho tiempo atrás,
que muestra las flotas pesqueras en el mar de Aral.
¿Ven el canal que cavan?
Estaban tan desesperados de tratar de que los botes flotaran en
lo que quedaba de agua... pero finalmente tuvieron que rendirse
porque los muelles y amarres simplemente no podían
mantenerse al día con el litoral que se retiraba.
No se Uds., pero me aterra que futuros
arqueólogos caven esto y escriban historias de
nuestro tiempo, y se pregunten, "¿En qué estaban pensando?"
Bien, ese es el futuro que tenemos que afrontar.
Ya estamos usando el 50% del agua dulce de la Tierra
que es sostenible, y la sola agricultura
es un 70% de eso.
Así que usamos mucha agua, mucha tierra en agricultura.
También usamos mucho de la atmósfera para la agricultura.
Usualmente cuando pensamos en la atmósfera
pensamos en cambio climático y gases de efecto invernadero
y principalmente en energía,
pero resulta que la agricultura es también uno de los mayores emisores
de gases de efecto invernadero.
Si miran el CO2 de la
quema de selva húmeda tropical,
o el metano de la vacas y el arroz,
o el oxido nitroso de muchos fertilizantes,
resulta que la agricultura aporta el 30% de los gases de efecto
invernadero que van a la atmósfera por actividad humana.
Esto es más que todos nuestros transportes.
Es más que toda nuestra electricidad.
Es más que toda la otra manufactura, de hecho.
Es el principal emisor individual de gases de efecto invernadero
de cualquier actividad humana en el mundo.
Y sin embargo, no hablamos mucho de ello.
Así que tenemos esta increíble presencia de agricultura hoy,
dominando nuestro planeta
que viene siendo el 40% de la superficie de tierra,
el 70% de uso de agua,
el 30% de la emisión de gases con efecto invernadero
Hemos duplicado el flujo de nitrógeno y fosfatos
alrededor del mundo solo por usar fertilizantes,
causando grandes problemas de calidad de agua en los ríos,
lagos y hasta océanos, y es también la mayor causa de
pérdida de biodiversidad.
Así que sin duda la agricultura es
la fuerza más poderosa desatada en este planeta
desde la edad del hielo. Sin duda.
Y rivaliza con el cambio climático en importancia.
Y los dos están sucediendo al mismo tiempo.
Pero lo importante para recordar es que
no todo es malo. No es que la agricultura sea una cosa mala.
De hecho, dependemos completamente de ella.
No es opcional. No es un lujo. Es absolutamente necesaria.
Necesitamos proveer comida y pienso y, sí,
fibras e incluso biocombustibles para algo así como 7 mil millones de personas
en el mundo hoy, y si pasa algo,
es que esas demandas a la agricultura
aumentarán en el futuro. No va a desaparecer.
Va a ser aún mayor, principalmente por el
aumento de la población. Somos 7 mil millones hoy
llegando al menos a 9,
probablemente nueve y medio hasta parar.
Más importante, con cambio de dieta.
Conforme el mundo se vuelve más sano y más populoso,
aumentamos nuestro consumo de carne,
lo que consume más recursos que la comida vegetariana.
Así que más personas, comen más y con más abundancia
y claro, con una crisis energética al mismo tiempo
por la que tenemos que reemplazar petróleo por otras fuentes
lo que en última instancia tendrá que incluir más biocombustibles
y fuentes de bioenergía.
Así que pongan todo junto. Es realmente duro ver
cómo vamos a lograrlo para el resto del siglo
sin doblar al menos la producción agrícola global.
Bien, ¿cómo vamos a hacerlo? ¿Cómo vamos a
doblar la agricultura global en el mundo?
Bueno, podemos cultivar más tierra.
Este es el análisis que hicimos, en la izquierda es donde
hay cultivos hoy, en la derecha donde los debería haber,
basados en suelos y clima, suponiendo que el cambio climático
no haga mucho daño a esto,
que no es una buena presunción.
Podemos cultivar más tierra, pero el problema es
que las tierras restantes son áreas sensibles.
Tienen mucha diversidad, mucho carbono,
cosas que queremos proteger.
Así que podemos cultivar más expandiendo las tierras de labrantío
pero es mejor no hacerlo,
porque ecológicamente es muy, muy peligroso hacerlo.
En cambio, quizá queramos congelar la huella
de la agricultura y trabajar mejor las tierras que tenemos.
Este es trabajo que estamos haciendo para resaltar los lugares
en el mundo donde podemos mejorar los rendimientos
sin dañar el medioambiente.
Las áreas verdes aquí muestran dónde se da el maíz,
solo muestra el maíz como ejemplo,
ya es muy alta, probablemente lo máximo que se puede encontrar
en la Tierra hoy para este clima y suelo,
pero las áreas marrones y amarillas, son lugares
donde solo hay un 20 o 30% del rendimiento
que se podría lograr.
Ven muchas en África, incluso en Latinoamérica,
pero noten que en Europa del este, donde la Unión Soviética
y los países del Bloque del este estaban,
la agricultura es todavía un desastre.
Ahora, esto requiere nutrientes y agua.
Será u orgánica o convencional
o alguna mezcla de las dos.
Las plantas necesitan agua y nutrientes.
Pero podemos hacerlo y hay oportunidades para hacer este trabajo.
Pero tenemos que hacerlo de forma que sea sensible
para cubrir la seguridad de alimentos del futuro
y la seguridad medio ambiental necesaria en el futuro.
Tenemos que ver cómo hacemos esta compensacón entre
cultivar comida y tener un ambiente sano, que funcione mejor.
Ahora mismo, es una especie de 'todo o nada'.
Podemos cultivar comida en el fondo
—este es un campo de soya—
y en este diagrama de flor, se muestra que cultivamos mucha comida
pero no tenemos mucha agua limpia, no reservamos
mucho carbono, no tenemos mucha biodiversidad.
En primer plano, tenemos esta pradera
magnífica desde el punto de vista ambiental,
pero no puedes comer nada. ¿Qué hay para comer?
Tenemos que ingeniarnos la forma de unirlas
en un nuevo tipo de agricultura que nos dé ambas cosas.
Ahora, cuando hablo de esto, la gente con frecuencia me dice:
"Bien, ¿no es obvia la respuesta? Comida orgánica, comida local,
organismos modificados genéticamente, nuevos subsidios al comercio y a las granjas".
Y sí, tenemos cantidades de buenas ideas,
pero ninguna es una varita mágica.
De hecho, lo que creo es que hay más como trucos mágicos.
Y adoro los trucos. Los pones juntos
y obtienes algo de verdad poderoso,
pero necesitamos ponerlos juntos.
Así que lo que tenemos que hacer, creo, es inventar una nueva forma
de agricultura que mezcle las mejores ideas
de la agricultura comercial y la revolución verde
con las mejores ideas de la agricultura orgánica y la comida local
y las mejores ideas de conservación del ambiente,
no tenerlos luchando uno con otro, sino tenerlos
colaborando juntos en una nueva forma de agricultura,
algo que llamo "terracultura" o cultivo para todo el planeta.
Ahora, tener esta conversación es de verdad duro
y nosotros hemos intentado con ahínco traer estos puntos claves
a la gente para reducir la controversia
y aumentar la colaboración.
Quiero mostrarles un video corto que trata de mostrar el tipo
de esfuerzos que estamos haciendo para unir estos lados
en una única conversación. Déjenme mostrárselos.
(Música)
("Instituto de Medioambiente, Universidad de Minnesota: Guiando el descubrimiento)
("La población mundial crece
75 millones de personas cada año.
Esto es casi la población de Alemania.
Hoy somos cerca de 7 mil millones de personas.
A este paso, seremos 9 mil millones para el 2040.
Y todos necesitamos comida.
¿Pero qué?
¿Cómo podemos alimentar al mundo sin destruir el planeta?
Ya sabemos que el cambio climático es un gran problema.
Pero no es el único problema.
Necesitamos enfrentar 'la otra verdad incómoda'.
Una crisis global en la agricultura.
Aumento de la población + consumo de carne + consumo de leche + costos energéticos + producción de bioenergía = estrés de los recursos naturales.
Más del 40% de los suelos de la Tierra se han despejado para agricultura.
Los cultivos globales cubren 16 millones de km².
Esto es casi el tamaño de Suramérica.
Los pastizales globales cubren 30 millones de km².
Es el tamaño de África.
La agricultura usa 60 veces más tierra que las áreas urbanas y suburbanas combinadas.
La irrigación es el mayor uso del agua del planeta.
Usamos 2 000 kilómetros cúbicos de agua en cultivos cada año.
Es tanto como llenar 7 305 Empire States cada día.
Hoy, muchos grandes ríos están reducidos a arroyos.
Algunos se secaron del todo.
Miren el mar de Aral, ahora un desierto.
O el río Colorado, que ya no llega al océano.
Los fertilizantes han más que duplicado los fosfatos y el nitrógeno del ambiente.
¿La consecuencia?
Polución generalizada del agua
y degradación masiva de lagos y ríos.
Sorprendentemente, la agricultura es el mayor contribuyente del cambio climático.
Genera el 30% de los gases de efecto invernadero.
Es más que la emisión de toda la electricidad y la industria
de todos los aviones, trenes y automóviles del mundo.
Muchas emisiones por agricultura vienen de la desforestación tropical,
el metano de los animales y los campos de arroz,
el oxido nitroso de la fertilización alta.
No hay nada que hayamos hecho que transforme más al mundo que la agricultura.
Y nada es más crucial para nuestra sobrevivencia.
Este es el dilema...
Conforme el mundo crece en varios miles de millones de personas,
necesitamos duplicar, quizá triplicar, la producción global de comida.
Así que, ¿a dónde vamos?
Necesitamos una gran conversación, un diálogo internacional.
Necesitamos invertir en soluciones reales:
incentivos para agricultores, agricultura de precisión, nuevas variedades de cultivos, irrigación por goteo,
reciclar aguas negras, mejores prácticas de labranza, dietas inteligentes.
Necesitamos a todos en la mesa.
Defensores de la agricultura comercial,
ambientalistas,
granjeros orgánicos...
necesitamos trabajar juntos.
No hay una única solución.
Necesitamos colaboración,
imaginación,
determinación,
porque fallar no es una opción.
¿Cómo alimentamos el mundo sin destruirlo?")
Sí, enfrentamos uno de los mayores retos
de toda la historia de la humanidad:
necesitamos alimentar 9 mil millones de personas
y hacerlo de forma sostenible, equitativa y justa,
a la vez que protegemos nuestro planeta
para esta y las siguientes generaciones.
Esta será una de las cosas más difíciles
que haya hecho la humanidad en su historia
y tenemos que hacerlo muy bien,
y hacerlo bien en nuestro primer y quizá único intento.
Muchas gracias. (Aplausos)